hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to uncanny valley a
pixelated exceptionally highly rated
indie horror game and I just wanted to
take a moment to drink in what in the
world is happening on this main menu
there you meathook hanger thingies with
what I can only assume to be human skins
on them there's blood dripping from the
ceiling one lone liner blah blah blah
appeal a slit down a blow the severed
heads on the right and left and there
can only be organs and bags of blood in
the center so that's what I have to look
forward to in this game so I eagerly
await what could go wrong let's split up
it's spring break
let's just have a few brews it'll be
fine I think something's going wrong
here recommended headphones a dark room
play night well it's night and I'm in a
semi dark room but headphones are an
impossibility because there's a TV over
here anyway I'm gonna get into it I
won't be in this space much longer I
will not be recording on a couch I will
be back in my normal setup as soon as I
can I live nearby i i i should get home
do i live in these woods
or do i live in this way well you're
here a little early
okay I wondered what huh
you
excuse me I just started the game good
god you shut up here what was it a dream
I don't know you got mauled to death by
shadow creatures hello hi oh god they're
back what what do i do what do I do
ha ha
okay this have have I passed out I can't
get any sleep lately well no wonder the
shadow creature poured out of the walls
come out of everywhere
sleeping in broad daylight yeah plus
these horrible nightmares oh yeah
nightmares aren't exactly helping this
game is off to a bit of a bit of a rough
start don't you think I miss my front
door and I got dumped
I shouldn't have gone
all right done
guess I'm playing the game now locked
I'll have to find a key card what do you
mean you're a security guard the door
seems to sturdy to destroy yeah I will
admit those heavy solid steel bolts
ordinarily would be child's play for a
man of your caliber right now is it uh
why is my flashlight mount oh it's a
wall that's why my flashlights not
penetrating that darkness whoopsies okay
so can I go in here yeah yeah I trust
that a bunch of baloney
okay sign I didn't well that's a penis
that's a penis and balls and it's full
of mannequins what the hell is going on
here I didn't even look down I was too
distracted by the penis and ovaries
along with the rest of the Jane key card
why is it on a mannequin why is there an
axe this is my weapon old VCR tape I
wonder if I can play it well not on your
ownself oh that one's looking at me why
this game I just started forgive me how
do I get out my weapon I wasn't really
looking at the controls in the beginning
so I can only assume sign it doesn't
read why would I do that why would I do
that why would I do that okay whatever I
did it so do
wait a minute doesn't seem right
why is there a bedroom in here huh
what Oh make any thought I saw something
okay no okay maybe I can play the VCRs
here observation uh okay which one's the
earliest I guess that would be this one
but there's something important circled
there this is the earliest I'm a crotch
like that I'm a crossover here yeah yeah
I'm a security guard and nothing gonna
get by me
yeah I'm really still think now that I'm
one foot lower than I was before
yeah yeah they gonna give me a okay
anyway that's enough fun time for
serious business uh press space to press
ENTER to watch okay here we are that's a
man here that was in the other room ah
excuse me
so oh I get it okay I did that I did it
by pressing down wait a minute that's
not good cuz those were these things why
is there a big sign of the penis in of a
GU on the wall why is that a thing it's
not appropriate for children boob Oh
what are those oh yeah I gotta be still
see Hannah be as stealthy as possible
oh god what is that let's look at ripped
open human ah a bit of body parts yeah
zere doors what's doing here oh sorry
what's this doing here
I didn't read the rest of that couldn't
oh oh oh oh oh no my class I went out
don't worry this is getting him by me oh
just a hurry what
aggghhhhh my head I'm back in my old
what it's getting cold I I'm freezing
these damn nightmares again what are you
talking about well this balloon is at my
blood so all my blood
not my blood all over the walls kids me
that shoot me what why am i back here
why man then again I I don't think I
ever mentioned this is only a demo they
locked me in
who did the disembodied body parts did
they lock you in alright then oh god
damn like I know I know that some people
have like an aversion he's pixelated
what I just collapsed oh I thought I'd
die bye ma'am Gabby Gabby Keon dude um
hmm I guess he ran out of batteries or
something uh can say I'm crouching or
else he really would have gotten me it's
just good to show the crouching is a
little stealthy way to move possible
I'm oh did I make it through I'm any -
ah all right
ah get up I need to get out of here I
agree completely oh I'm moving okay
thank you whoo ha ha ha right ah ah
I was terrifying this is fantastic
oh it's beautiful let's beautiful God
those terrifying I don't even know what
it was it's like as soon as I share the
game just like boom everything is wrong
oh man those fantastic God those
fantastic you don't understand
those fantastic or maybe you probably
understand that was fantastic I was
beautiful I loved it
a plus 10 out of 10 oh god I want to
play more it was jumping back and forth
because it was a demo I imagine in the
full game there's going to be a lot more
like in between the stories I don't know
if it's the same character if it's just
two different people I don't know I want
to know I wanted to know so badly ah I
was so cool Hey all right it's only way
you can check out this game in the
website listed uh I'll put a link in the
description below you can check out more
scary games that I've done but god damn
this was amazing I'd loved it to death
so either way thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
scary games that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
talks to baby by the way great
Oh
very lighted